- [Voiceover] Lola asked her classmates
their favorite type of movie
and graphed the results.
All right so it says that 20 people
said their favorite type
of movie was comedy.
Six people said their favorite
type of movie was scary.
10 people said their favorite
type of movie was adventure.
10 people also said their favorite
type of movie is cartoons.
And then 16 people said their favorite
type of movie is a mystery.
All right, so let's
read the questions here.
So which of the following types of movies
were picked by fewer than 14 people?
So fewer than 14 people.
So more than 14 picked comedy or mystery.
So this line right over here would be 14.
So fewer than 14 were
scary, adventure, cartoon.
This was six people, 10
people, and 10 people.
Scary, adventure, and cartoon.
So we wanna pick scary,
adventure, and cartoon.
These three had less
than 14 people pick them.
So let's do a couple more of these.
Let's do a couple more.
Puppy Party Place graphed
the number of dogs
that came in each weekday.
So let's see, 80 dogs came in on Monday,
160 dogs came in on Tuesday,
80 dogs came in on Wednesday.
140 dogs came in on Thursday,
and then Friday was a very popular day,
180 dogs came in to the
Puppy Party Place on Friday.
All right, so what are they asking us?
On which day did the same number of dogs
come to Puppy Party Place,
as on Monday and Wednesday combined?
All right, so let's see,
Monday and Wednesday combined.
So on Monday we had 80 puppies
come there, or 80 dogs.
And on Wednesday we had 80 dogs.
And they're saying which day had the same
as Monday and Wednesday combined?
So Monday and Wednesday
combined would be 80
plus 80, which would be 160.
So on which of these
days did 160 dogs come?
Well we see it right over here, 160 dogs,
that was on Tuesday, and only on Tuesday.
So Tuesday, let's do a few more of these.
Dessert Zone asked its customers about
their favorite ice cream flavor,
and graphed the results.
So 175 customers said
vanilla, 225 said chocolate,
75 said strawberry, and
200 said cookie dough.
All right, how many more customers picked
the most popular flavor than
the least popular flavor?
All right, so the most
popular flavor was chocolate,
that was 225, and the
least popular flavor...
To the least popular flavor,
it's a tongue twister, was 75.
So how many more picked the most popular
than the least popular?
Well the most popular was
225, the least popular was 75.
So what's 225 minus 75?
Let's see, 225 minus 25 would be 200,
minus 50 would be 175.
Minus 75 would be 150.
So we get 150 customers.
And once again, we're saying that
150 more customers picked chocolate,
the most popular flavor,
than the least popular.
Another way you could do it is you could
look at the least popular
and the most popular
and say well how many
more do I have to add
to the least popular to
get to the most popular?
And you see 25, 50, 75,
100, 125, 150.
Each of these lines is 25 more.
So there you have it, 150 more customers
liked the most popular flavor, chocolate,
than the least popular flavor.